hey youtubers it's Charlie since a lot
of you have been asking me to do an ask
emergency Q&A session for Walking Dead
here it is so I thought we'd try to
answer some questions about what's going
to be happening on the show in 2014 if
you haven't seen any of my ask emergency
Q&A videos yet I typically pick about 10
of your questions to answer in a video
my next Q&A video will actually be a
personal one so you can ask me any
questions you want about me myself or me
in real life and as long as they're not
too gross I will try to answer them be
sure to subscribe to get that
so Walking Dead 2014 questions here we
go number one
Alex Wooley asks do you think the next
half of season four will mainly follow
Rick and Carl
so Andrew Lincoln is the main character
from AMC's perspective he gets paid the
most so if you were to count the number
of everyone's scenes after the entire
season is over he would have the most
but there are four groups that we'll see
when the show comes back so for all
intents and purposes each group will get
the same amount of time we'll know
exactly who's in which group after
episode nine number two Daniel RDO asks
who's your favorite character right now
my favorite character is Daryl Norman
Reedus said this really awesome thing
that Daryl hates the idea of being
responsible for other people but because
of what happens to Rick at the end of
season 3 and where that character goes
in season four so far Daryl has been
forced to become a leader they do have
the council technically but based on the
events of the mid-season finale I think
we can consider that disbanded so
whichever group Daryl ends up in he'll
end up leading number three
doomageddon asks if Tyreese finds Carol
do you think that he'll kill her Scott
Gimple will probably hang that over our
heads briefly but I don't think we'll
see her again till much much later in
the season so he will have mellowed down
just a little bit by the time he meets
her so I don't think that he'll kill her
but he'll never trust her again
number four gamers region asks will all
the group's meet up again I think that
at least two of the four groups will
meet up before the finale I don't think
that everyone will be reunited though
remember how some characters like Morgan
went away for almost two seasons number
five Michele Sloane II asks how long
will the groups be separated and how
many of them will make it to the safe
zone since the major conflicts that make
up the season finales each year end up
covering more than one episode I think
that the groups will probably end up
meeting by at least episode thirteen or
fourteen obviously I don't expect them
all to be reunited but at least a couple
groups will probably run into each other
the same goes for the safe zone just
because groups might meet up does
they'll make it to the safe zone
everyone will not make it to the safe
zone by the end of the season number six
mr. revitalise asks what is your
favorite season of The Walking Dead and
do you think the season four can end up
being the best right now my favorite
season is season four just because they
got rid of the prison and they got rid
of the governor so from a story
standpoint they can take the characters
anywhere they want to go obviously
they've already kind of plotted it out a
little bit based on the comic books but
the problem after season three was this
big unresolved issue about the fate of
the governor he was the main villain it
would be like Star Wars never telling
you what happened to Darth Vader after
Empire Strikes Back
number seven nerd life reviews asks do
you think that Rick could die on the
show good question
Robert Kirkman actually said that no one
is off-limits that being said the main
show will be over after season 5 that's
also the same season the spin-off will
start and none of the current characters
will be in the spin-off so I think that
Rick will died during season 5
ultimately I don't think the show is a
hopeful show it's not optimistic I don't
think they'll ever find a solution to
the virus which means that everyone will
die eventually number 8
Slender Man pray asks do you think that
we'll see the governor or Hershel as
walkers I definitely think that we'll
see the governor getting Nam Don just a
little bit whenever episode 9 comes back
but Lily shot him in the head so he's
not going to turn and even though
Hershel was only beheaded Scott Gimple
has this real sense of reverence for
Hershel so I don't think that he would
troll us by making us see Hershel as a
bitey head number 9 Adamski spiro asks
who do you find the least epic this is
like asking which character I think is
the most lame right now I think that Bob
Stokey is the lamest after the whole
run-in with Daryl and the bottle of
alcohol bob basically became the biggest
[ __ ] on the show look at it this way
Lizzie went from being this scared
little teenage girl to shooting one of
the governors people she's the badass
now and Bob Stokey is basically like the
opposite of that in my opinion if you're
a character on The Walking Dead you're
either a badass or you're cattle for
walkers it's just the law of the jungle
number 10
Camille Parker asks what's up with baby
Judith there's a lot of different
opinions but I think that Tyreese
grabbed her just because he and Lizzie
were the closest to her when everyone
took off running into the woods the
straps on the stroller were unbuckled so
she definitely wasn't eaten and isn't it
just funny to think about Tyreese
playing mommy for a couple of episodes
and a bonus question
Elijah Evans asks
what do you think the big reveal will be
at the end of this season good question
so everybody turned the volume down
right now for just a second if you don't
want any potential spoilers for season
five either it will be the reveal of
Gareth as the leader of the hunters or
will be negan right now my money is on
the reveal of negan there are eight more
episodes in the season and everyone just
can't only be wandering for eight more
hours of the show there has to be a new
antagonist that everyone can point their
fingers at and say that's the villain
and Abraham who we know is coming on the
show is going to be a friendly so it has
to be someone else which means the
hunters just because in the comic books
the hunters come before negan in the
show loosely mirrors the comic books it
doesn't follow them exactly you can turn
the volume back up now spoilers over
thank you so much everyone for
submitting your questions this is a lot
of fun again my next Walking Dead video
will just be a regular bonus video be
sure to subscribe to get it my next Q&A
video will actually be a personal video
so you can ask me any questions about
myself what I do in real life or how I
make videos or what I'm looking forward
to doing with my channel as long as the
questions aren't too gross I will
definitely try to answer all of them
right now click here to get my top 10
anticipated moments on The Walking Dead
when it comes back next year and click
here to learn all about anime club it's
a new show that I'm gonna be starting in
January thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives